eine neue folge wie schmeckt wie strange
[Musik]
hallo leute ich jetzt wieder einmal
waren willkommen zu einer neuen folge
wie schmeckt er es war lange her seit
wir das hier gemacht haben bin ich eher
nicht und bei mir auch ins gras beißen
sich schon länger vor hat es geschmeckt
zu drehen stranger sachen sind
dazwischen passiert deswegen ja
entschuldigung wenn ihr da jetzt lange
drauf gewartet habt aber heute gibt es
sie endlich die stranger springs wo
extravaganza was string thing staffel
zwei bis drei minuten 550 und das rezept
gibt es in meinem kopf erstlinge der
beschreibung führt euch zum buch und
wenn ihr euch das über den link
bestellen
der sommer ist echt wieder da und die
ganz tolle rezepte aus dem geschwätz
folgen oder ganz neue rezepte haben
wollt dann holt euch unbedingt dieses
buch das gibt es schon seit ende märz
und jetzt mein ganzer stolz
kommen wir zu den zutaten für unsere
strange things waffeln brauchen wir 150
g mehl 1 teelöffel natron eine prise
salz 3 eier der himmel bedürftiger
weiche butter die ich ist noch kalt weil
ich vergessen habe sie vorher aus dem
kühlschrank rauszuholen wenn ihr vorhabt
etwas zu backen
schaut immer schon mal vorher nach ob
eure butter kalt oder warm sein soll und
bereitet euch besser vor als ich und
sich an zucker diabetes
die hat will man im extrakt zwar bemühte
mich und zu guter letzt brauchen wir für
den waffelteig sonnenblumenöl
bevor ihr irgendwas passiert sollte man
sich immer die haare zusammen bin
und ein kleiner disclaimer ich weiß
nämlich dass die eigentlichen waffeln
die verwendet werden ego waffeln sind
warum es dann auch ergo extravaganza
heiß aber egos kriegt man eigentlich nur
den usa und kann natürlich sachen auf
aus den usa bestellen da sie aber tief
gefroren sind wäre glaube ich die
lieferung ultra kompliziert und mega
teuer um aber trotzdem diese form zu
kriegen habe ich ein extra waffeleisen
dafür besorgt diese runde waffeleisen
form ohne erzieherin ist auch relativ
typisch in den usa denke unser budget
ist ein handelsübliches waffeleisen
machst du hier klickst kannst du drehen
um den optimalen komfort für deine waffe
zu erstellen
nun sind sie oft her ich habe gerade
clever reisen
aber zuerst unsere kitchen
nein ich muss jetzt ja nur noch die
zombies
[Musik]
sh manchester
für alle die die strange things noch
nicht gesehen haben kurze
zusammenfassung worum es geht es geht um
eine gruppe von kindern in den 80ern und
eine davon kam
tolle sachen ist ziemlich stark und dann
gibt es ein großes schwarzes monster
beutling mega wie sie klingt mega
strange und genauso aufregend wie die
dritte staffel strange things war geht
es jetzt hier weiter
mir ist gerade aufgewacht und hab
richtig kann zurzeit nicht mehr gut
überlegt sage ich netflix weil
eigentlich bezahlen die mich ja nicht
dafür und dann sollte man das lieber
nicht sagen
gedreht wird und täglich wenn du
möchtest dann nochmal netflix sage dann
will ich scheine da scheint mir zu der
zubereitung mit in die schüssel trip.de
die könnten wir ja gerne mal in die
kommentare schreiben ob ihr schon
strange things geschaut hat und wie ihr
die dritte staffel fandet das würde mich
wirklich interessieren ich fand sie gut
ist aber jetzt kommt das matrone mission
im all und folgt die krise sei es die
trockenen zutaten werden nun miteinander
vermengt
in einer feier mit butter zucker wenn
der lexmark milch verrühren danach mit
der mischung vermengen dass keine bühne
mehr übrig sind derzeit 20 minuten ruhen
lassen
unsere mutter ist weich geworden und
kann in die schüssel hinein gefügt
werden billiger für insider nicht
vergessen das ist mir ganz klar wird er
ist eigentlich die krassere mathilda
größte das material könnte ja auch mal
so sagen sonst überall ist nur so und
nun kommt die chemikalie exzellente
[Musik]
extrakt das schwarze tor
bevor die mich dazu kommen möchte ich es
schon mal einmal verrühren und einen
tipp die eier und die milch und so kurz
vorher alles raus aus dem kühlschrank
holen weil wir ja weiche butter haben
und wenn wir kalte zutaten zu dieser
weiche butter packen dann wird halt
alles so klingt nicht ganz
however als kommt die mittel dazu also
im buch steht es nicht dass man was zu
abgetrennten einander machen soll man
kann es auch ganz anders kann das alles
vielleicht erledige sie hauen auf
früheren drücken und dann geht's
trotzdem jetzt machen wir unsere
mischung in die flüssige schüssel ein
wir hören so lange bis keine klümpchen
mehr zu sehen sind verteilt sollte jetzt
ungefähr so aussehen
man muss ein bisschen flüssiger sein so
wie hier damit er sich im watt reifen
auf dem verteilen aber bevor wir sie
backen dass wir sie noch ungefähr
zwanzig minuten später und jetzt geht es
ans backen
ok wenn mehrfach ist der teig so nach
transparenten wieder so ein bisschen
[Musik]
hoch
jetzt muss sich der sache leisen
erhitzen brauchen ungefähr eine fast
volle kenny cooper bis und mit dem
pinsel wir ein bisschen das war
vielleicht damit auch nichts hängen
läuft und jetzt machen wir die erste
waffe
[Musik]
so klein war schlecht aus nur bisschen
paar matratzen und damit unsere waffen
schön knusprig abkühlen lege ich sie auf
einem gitter
dies so schön gold geht goldig geworden
so professionell ist dieses schiff
welches weiß nicht ob man immer rauch
machen muss aber hätte werden als
geschmacksträger fett es ja
geschmackssache zu klappen
[Musik]
und während unsere waffen jetzt noch
abkühlen zeige ich euch die zutaten fürs
shopping und damit alle waffen schon
zusammenhalten benutzen wir die allseits
beliebte marshmallow creme
ich weiß nicht warum ich habe sie aus
amerika gekauft wie gibt's natürlich
auch in deutschland und ich weiß dass
zwischen den waffeln könnte auf sahne
sei weil natürlich sahne auch sehr zum
waffenpass aber ich bin ganz ehrlich mit
euch ich finde nicht dass visanne
aussieht es könnte sein dass es während
des films also keine echte sahne benutzt
wurde sondern irgendwas andere ist damit
das halt aber ich fand das irgendwie ne
nette idee einfach und kriegen zu
benutzen
das ist hat das auch so ein bisschen zum
torten charakter oder so in diesen
süßigkeiten charakter den ist ja eh
schon hat wegen chiligreen und herrsche
skepsis jelly beans kennt eigentlich
fast jeder das sind sogar boden
besonders bekannt wurden durch harry
potter verwies kisses musste ich auch
aus england bestellen weil sie in
deutschland noch nicht verkauft werden
das sind einfach schock oder obst das
sieht ja auch in meinem kopf hoch das
sind einfach so einfach so wie kleine
scheißhaufen eigentlich und ich habe
mich bei den größeren bisschen gewundert
ich hatte halt online bestellt und hatte
nicht so eine vorstellung davon was 43
gramm sind ja das sind 390 gramm und
falls ihr so eine naschkatze seit ich
könnte ja auch schokolinsen noch drauf
und jetzt geht es ans dekorieren der
beste teil
zuerst brauchen wir einen teller wir
nehmen die hässlichste waffel ganz unten
oh mein gott
so da kommt unser zweiter auch bei der
creme könnt ihr natürlich entscheiden
wie viel ihr haben wollt das ist man
auch nicht alle tage so könig
sie sind wie schön es hier raus
das lasse ich so das ist so und jetzt
tiefer
jetzt kommt der wichtigste teil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die lakritz nämlich raus wer mag schon
da kriegt man auch so ein paar zu
weihnachten im moment auf die leute
wisst ihr was kommt wir stellen uns
wieder der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmeckt der triple decker ego
extravaganza aus stranger will jetzt
fühle ich mich so richtig wie in der
szene in der eleven und habe gemeinsam
in der küche diesen waffen berg gegessen
haben er hat echt ne geile geburtstags
druckt allem ein zuckerschock so locker
wie kann etwas was so süß ist so gut
geschmeckt
ein problem ich noch bevor
ich bin auf diät ich habe natürlich hat
die folge gefallen und wenn ja dann sex
wie brennen darf nach oben schaut euch
gerne mein kochbuch anfang zehnmal im
buchhandel seit oder so geht's zu den
kochbüchern und meistens liegt es da es
ist ein kleines hobby von mir geworden
irgendwelche buchhandlung zu gehen und
mein buch dort anzuschauen und was ich
schon immer mal machen wollte ist mit
edding einfach meine bücher signieren
ich weiß aber nicht ob man das überhaupt
darf also ich darf er quasi meine bücher
signieren aber ich glaube dass finde
trotzdem nicht jeder buchverkäufer
irgendwie cool mit die da unten steht
muss man schreibt mir natürlich wie
immer gerne was ich als nächstes
ausprobieren soll
ich werde mich auch jetzt richtig spuren
und wieder mehr geschmeckt videos für
euch produziert ich weiß ihr wünscht
euch das immer wieder und sagt mir das
immer wieder und ich freue mich
natürlich über jede idee die ihm schickt
also und geht ein bisschen raus es ist
sommer es war
die haut